hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round 11 of the
2018 candidates tournament here we have
eleven Iranian with the white pieces
against Sergey Kerrigan and it's very
interesting how do you approach this
tournament it's already round 11 you're
11 are in and you only have three and a
half points out of 10 games that were
just played how do you proceed to do
still try and win games do you just want
to maybe draw the rest the rest of the
games and stop stopped bleeding
what's the idea here so it's it's very
interesting because it's different in
the candidates tournament in candidates
it doesn't really matter if you win
second third fourth fifth place only the
first place matters and after aragon
lost that game to pramukh in round three
it seems all of the games simply went
downhill from him for him but ok let's
see let's see the the game and also we
do have some nice photos and as a
suggestion from a subscriber I decided
to show for this one occasion the photos
in full screen so we do have a Sergey
kurakin here a nice close up here we
have 11 area and deep in thought and
here we have also a photo of Sergey
pondering over the position and notice
that notice that arena now does have a
coffee saucer under his mug which could
mean that he decided to take up sugar
after his game with with Wesley so so
let's see the game we have a c4 by 11
Knight to f6
we have Knight to f3 and e 6 so the
English opening g3 we have d5 and now
Bishop to G to the Catalan variation of
the English d captures on c4 Queen to f4
check c5 c6 and Queen captures on c4
immediately grabbing the pawn b5 by
Sergey and here in this position in most
cases and whenever I saw this I saw
Queen to c2 but here 11 plays Queen to
b3 and no doubt this is again yet yet
another home preparation by Levin
Bishop to b7 we have castles now Bishop
to e7 and d4 Sergey castles rook to d1
and the Knight B to d7 ni to e5 with the
idea that this Knight is an excellent
piece on e5 and if Sergei captures it
then B captures on e5 will create a nice
open file for the rook but Sergei does
it we have Knight captures the D
captures only five and now Knight to d7
and here f4 does seem like the way to go
here but Aragon plays Bishop to f4 and
now this does seem like like an
empowered pawn yet again but it's
definitely something he prepared at home
Queen to c7 now targeting the spawn and
night - D - preparing Knight to f3 or
maybe nice to e4 depending on world
black plays we have rook F to d8 and the
rook F to d8 it was an interesting
decision certainly could have gone for
g5 but you can see with this weird
positioning of the Queen um b3 the
bishop on f4 why would you allow g5
Bishop to e3 you could simply capture
this pawn here but after rook a to C 1
this was probably what 11 had in mind
black did win a pawn here but he's not
better why was why it's almost done
which is a complete development he can
always go 94 attack that pawn and g5 he
can break open with wood h4 with the
knight on e4 he's controlling c5 so
black I never pushed c5 this Bishop on
b7 will remain a silly piece so not
really something black should go for but
okay rook F to d8 bye-bye kurakin rook
to c1 and now a6 Queen to e3 and again
Queen to e3 probably a home preparation
idea as the this Knight thief removed
that seemed like the way to go with the
idea that the knight can come to d6 the
knight is preventing the pawn to be
pushed to c5 also Knight to f6 is an
idea and here if black immediately wants
to go for c5 then why does have this
Knight to f6 move Bishop captures and
now pawn captures opening up a
discovered attack to the Queen he 5 now
blocking Bishop captures some b7 Queen
captures and after Bishop to e3
Knight captures on f6 you don't really
gain anything by pushing c4 white can
simply capture that as the point is
printed the Queen on b7 is undefended
so knife captures rook captures on c5
and it's it's a good position for both
white and black surely Aragon saw this
and decided not to go for it so instead
the Queen to e3 first now c5 immediately
opening up that light square bishop on
b7
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
Knight to e4 and from here this night
will will have a very nice outpost on d6
we have c4h for now h6 rook to d4
preparing to develop a knife to f8
offering to exchange rooks b3 rook
captures Queen captures and rook to d8
Knight to d6 finally Bishop captures
pawn captures and now f6 creating space
so the King can also help out with the
defense here and also preparing a5
Bishop to e3 not allowing not allowing
if I by winning a piece we have Quinta
b2 and now Quintus e6 pawn captures pawn
captures and now going to be for
protecting his pawn here and also
attacking the c4 pawn rook the c8
guarding the C pawn f3 now h5 into f2
and now King to f7 the King is now
coming into the game rook to d1 Knight
to d7 Queen to be one with the idea of
jumping all the way to h7 so g6
preventing this and now g4 rook to h8
and not allowing this this breakthrough
and the King side g5 simply closing the
position would f5 Queen to c2 and now
rogue back to c8 a queen to see three
King comes all the way to e6 King to g2
and now Queen to a for attacking the a
to pawn Queen to d2 defending it Queen
back to b5 and now a for a for an
interesting move of course you can't
capture upon if you capture then Queen
to d5 will be checked
- the pawns are covering all the dark
squares here so this would be very very
interesting about Queen the Queen to see
six of course Queen to c2 and now rook
to b8 Bishop to b2 rook to be three
blocking the Queen's defense of the a4
pawn and here for some reason
Aragon decided to defend his d6 pawn and
he played Bishop to c3 and he allowed he
allowed Kerrigan to capture this a4 pawn
which basically starts starts a very a
negative flow of the game for Aragon
after Bishop to beat after rook to b3
simply a5 and after black captures this
pawn you can go rook to c1 and okay you
lost the d6 pawn but you're gonna win
the c4 pawn there's really no way for
luck to defend it
there's no night the b6 move now the
bishop is covering all of the squares
here the rook can help out with the
defense of the c4 point so this would
have been excellent and I mean you're
still holding this game but he played
Bishop to c3 and now Queen captures on
a4 so he lost the pawn and now kirkin
has to passed pawns here rook to a1
Queen back to c6 and now rook to a5 okay
he does get some activity for the rock
but here comes Rock to b5 you don't want
to exchange rooks along and these pawns
to get connected Queen to a4 kind of
pinning the rock but Knight to b6
immediately kicking the Queen back Queen
to a-1 and now rook captures we have
Queen captures and now Queen to b5
offering a trade of Queens and you don't
really have a good move here again you
don't want to trade Queens as black will
get too connected passed pawns if you
move the Queen doesn't matter where then
black will simply improve the position
and keep pushing his advantage so here
are an untried d7 he sacrificed another
pawn to get to gain some counter play
Sergei grabbed at King capture son d7
and now Queen to a3 with ideas of
infiltrating the position with the Queen
but Sergei calculates everything
extremely precisely and he plays Knight
to d5 so he gives up d5 pawn but to wit
with extreme
precision knife capture Bishop Tadros on
e5 now Queen to c6 we have Queen to f8
and now Queen to e6 and now you'll see
how everything falls into place
Queen to b8 we have c3 now pushing his
passport Queen to b7 check King to e8
Queen to be a check King to f7 Queen -
b7 check and now this night that started
this whole variation comes finally to e7
and now the king is completely protected
Bishop captures on c3 you do have to
play something and now Queen captures an
e2 with check King to h3 and now Queen
to b5 here again offering a trade of
Queens Queen to c7 but now winter c6 and
this was I'm sure Sergey found all of
this when he played Knight to d5 and now
he's again offering a trade of Queens
he's offering to grab the bishop on c3
to grab the pawn on f3 and you can't
defend everything and this is this is
one horrible aspect of the game when
you're playing a game for like 6 hours
and you have an excellent game I mean
before Aragon decided to basically
blunder that a porn the position was
equal and then you give up the pawn and
then you realize that you no longer have
the option of trading Queens because the
the endgame without the Queen's is
winning for for Kerrigan
so that's one terrible thing that that
can happen to anyone it happened to me a
lot of times and you know that's there
are so so so few moves you can actually
play because all of the trades actually
favor the guy with the extra pawn but
okay Queen to e5 defending the rush of
Queen captures an f3 would check King to
h2 now Queen to f2 with check back into
h1 now giving up all of the pawns Queen
captures on h4 King g1 Queen captures on
g5 with check King gauge to Queen h4
check King to g1 and now again offering
a trade of Queens Queen g7 check
allowing this a small idea but nothing
to add Knight to d5 Bishop b2
and now f4 king h2 King comes into the
game King g5 King g4
comes King age for Bishop to g7 and now
Queen to e2 check King h1 and now Queen
to f3 check King to h2 and now Queen to
g3 check and it was in this position
that Aragon finally being a four pawns
down I resigned the game but only
because it's a force to checkmate after
Queen to g3 King H one Queen checks King
H 2 Queen checks on e to King moves now
King g3 and there's there's no defense
against all of these checkmates so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah quite a tournament for Aragon I
mean before I forget I did prepare the
final standings after round 11 here we
have a Caruana in first place with 7 7
points still leading this tournament
mama D ro still half a point behind in
second place but here we have it in
third and fourth place sharing with six
points Couric in English cook so Cara
can also had a terrible start to
determine but little by little he's
already here only half a point down
behind Fabiano Caruana we have then
being leerin would five and a half
points still continuing his perfect
streak Kramnik would 5 so with 4 and a
half and Ireland still with three and a
half points out of 11 games so it's
gonna be an interesting round 12 and I
have even the pairings here from round
12 today the district faces Argand we
shook as the white pieces and Aragon is
such a wounded beast now that the
district will be out for blood
definitely and you know the logic behind
it being that if everyone gets a point
from RN and Grisha will want one as well
with the white pieces especially and we
have a Kraken versus Caruana Cara can
also with white pieces so if you go
district wins against arena and if Cara
can wins against Caruana
then basically then basically anyone can
win this tournament it is all all hell
will break loose if this happens
and Mammadov does have a chance with the
white pieces against England maybe you
know start to get a win against England
he proved that it's hard to lose a game
against England he proved prove that
yesterday pretty clearly but you know
all of the runs here are very
interesting even chronic if he wins his
game against so he's after all all the
way up to six points so everyone can win
a game today and get and get their
chance at winning this tournament so
yeah those were the pairings and those
were the standings I do hope you enjoyed
that and it's it's a very interesting I
don't know what do you think is our
union losing this game because because
he just mad or maybe he's just totally
down for for losing so many games before
this game or is he just really just
trying to push these little advantages
and then and then gets worse positions
for some reason but blundering this a
pawn on purpose for no reason I don't
think that's something a 2800 player
would do especially if he was in the
lead in the tournament and there's
really nothing to achieve here by
playing such a move even winning this
game you might save a little rating at
the end by winning it but there's really
nothing to achieve here so yeah that's
it I do hope you enjoyed it I would like
to thank Anderson Luneberg for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and once
again I would like to thank Nikki for
her photos from the candidates
tournament as usual all of the links to
her social media will be in the
description below feel free to check out
some of her work thank you for watching
and yeah as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon